hi everyone I'm Laura Ingram this is the
Ingram angle from Washington tonight as
always thanks for being with us the
stunt man that's the focus of tonight's
Angle now when we're wrong here at the
angle we admit it and tonight is one of
those times for months heck for heck for
years we've warned that Joe Biden was
kind of checked out that he wasn't being
kept informed of serious crises and
frankly that he was incapable of
managing crises well
we were wrong he may not care about the
Border or fentel or inflation forget it
but Joe's very much locked in on solving
Hunter's legal troubles which are a
mortal threat to his reelection he said
that President Biden was familiar with
what his son was going to say on Capitol
Hill if I called my dad and said I am
about to violate a congressional
subpoena you probably say son you
shouldn't do that was there any attempt
by president B to talk Hunter out of it
I don't have anything else to add the
president was familiar with what um
Hunter was going to say of course Joe
Biden was familiar with what his son was
doing yesterday come on just as he was
familiar with what Hunter was doing when
he was vice president just as he knew
that his son was getting paid millions
of dollars from foreign entities and
that those entities expected something
in return if President Biden or his top
lawyers told Hunter not to pull that
show up to confront Congress D yesterday
Hunter wouldn't have done it so what I'm
telling you tonight is this is all
coordinated but axios the Biden house
Oregon soft pedals it saying Hunter's
team keeps the White House and Joe Biden
informed of its plans but the
president's team has far less control
over Hunter strategy than it once had
far less control oh please more like far
more spin the White House is helping
quarterback Hunter defense it has to
contrary to the arms length picture that
axios is trying to paint for us there's
no daylight between Hunter's attorney
Abby LEL and Biden's lawyers on Hunter's
legal strategy let's call this what it
is it's essentially a Joint Defense
agreement for the bidens it's never been
civil service it's more like sleazy
service because Joe has always put
himself and his family's interests ahead
of the countries for this reason Joe
Biden said nothing when his son
repeatedly and brazenly lied about his
laptop and in doing so even implicates a
foreign
government was that your laptop for real
I don't know I know but you know I
really don't know the answer is you
don't know yes or no if the laptop I
don't have any idea I have no idea what
so it could have been yours of course
certainly it there could be a laptop out
there that was stolen from me there
could be that I was hacked it could be
that that it was the that it was Russian
intelligence it could be that it was
stolen from me and you didn't drop off a
laptop to be repaired in Delaware not
that I remember at
all that never gets old and now caught
dead to rights getting rich using shell
bank accounts the big guy getting his
cut complaining in an email about his
dad taking half his income Hunter Biden
pulls a stunt to try to turn the tables
on Republicans and of course blame
Maga tried to dehumanize me all to
embarrass and damage my
father who has do devoted his entire
public life to
service for 6 years I have been the
target of the unrelenting Trump attack
machine shouting where's
Hunter the where's Hunter really got to
him now he refused to be questioned by
attorneys for republic rep an and
Democrats which is what would have
happened behind closed doors yesterday
and instead he tried to pull a Hillary
his version of blaming the vast
right-wing conspiracy for his own SAS
now one of my favorite moments was when
he tried to convince everyone that he's
really smart I'm proud to have earned
degrees from Georgetown University and Y
law school I'm proud of my legal career
and business career I'm proud of my time
serving on a dozen different Boards of
directors and I'm proud of my efforts to
forge Global business relationships
right because I'm sure if your name was
Hunter Jones you would have gotten into
Georgetown and Yale and made Millions
from a Chinese Energy company because of
all of your expertise now I'm not sure
which is less convincing in Hunter's
effort to help his dad that he
legitimately made all that money or that
the C made him do it in the depths of my
addiction I was extremely irresponsible
with my finances they have lied over and
over about every aspect of my personal
and professional life so much so that
their lies have become the false facts
believed by too many people but as the
Wall Street Journal noted Hunter's
alleged tax fraud occurred well after he
himself said he had gotten sober but
look the truth doesn't matter the bidens
it's all about their financial
enrichment and their political survival
because one depends on the other Hunter
needs to save his father because he
needs his father to save him he played
the loyal son angle in that axios
interview as well saying I feel I have
two equal responsibilities now the first
is staying clean and sober and the
second is defending my dad my mistakes
are in spite of him not a reflection of
him and that's why I need to call out
their lies as loud and as often as
possible going
forward look
grift is the Biden family business every
in Washington knows it everyone but
we're supposed to let it go for some
sentimental hmar Hallmark
fantasy and they have taken the light of
my dad's
love the light of my dad's love for me
and presented it as
Darkness they have no
shame as for the president himself he
making it known through selective leaks
that he's unhappy with his own doj and
these unnamed sources specifically say
that Biden is singling out AG Meritt
Garland they call it Biden's Hunter
trigger and the president apparently
feels guilty sad and angry when his son
is attacked Biden's relationship with
Garland which is already tense has
become more frigid amid Biden's
frustration at the lengthy criminal
investigation and now prosecution of
Hunter by the justice department now how
is this not Biden in the White House
meddling in an ongoing investigation
contrary to what they've always claimed
they weren't doing this is carefully
choreographed well-placed Anonymous
sources describing the president as
fuming at Meritt Garland and his having
appointed a special counsil in August
Biden even compared Garland to James
Comey for supposedly being obsessed with
the appearance of having Integrity
rather than just trying to make the
right
decision okay first of all having the
words Comey and integrity in the same
sentence now that's
funny perhaps the AG now understands
that the bidens are like The Sopranos
without any of the humor they protect
each other in the family business at all
costs Joe Biden doesn't care that
because of what he's allowed his son to
do every foreign leader and I I mean
everyone thinks that the White House
under Biden sells influence and the
president uses his own family to
collect so I say ask not what your
president did for his country ask who
paid his family Millions during his time
in
office if you think Hunter was paid
millions of dollars by sophisticated
foreign interests in all he delivered to
them all he gave them in return was a
few minutes on the phone with his dad
maybe a few holes of golf then I have a
time share in Gaza to sell
you I have no idea where this
impeachment inquiry is going to lead I
don't know what the political Fallout
will be one way or another but
yesterday's Stunt by Hunter was yet
another indication that his father is
not worried at all about protecting the
office of the presidency or frankly the
country because if it was he never would
have allowed his son to take a dime from
Ukraine Romania or China in the first
place and that is the angle hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else